uhh brain freeze it's awful that sharp
searing pain in your forehead but you
know what's even worse not everyone gets
it that's right
some people can suck down as many
milkshakes as they want and never feel a
thing life is so unfair and you know
what else is lucky people are ruining it
for scientists too brain freeze is one
of those scientific mysteries that's
been around since the 1800s just throw
it in there with UFOs crop circles we
may never know as a real reason behind
them maybe that's a bit of an
exaggeration but here's the thing the
leading theories for what causes a brain
freeze have to do with a physical
response that everyone should feel the
way scientists think it works is this
brain freeze happens when something cold
hits the roof of your mouth where it
triggers your trigeminal nerve it's the
nerve in charge of the sensations you
feel around the front of your head
that's why when you freeze it to
sub-zero temperatures the pain is around
the temple and the forehead in fact
different nerves cause pain in different
parts of your head a toothache for
example can irritate the mandibular
nerve causing pain near the central
skull but when it comes to brain freeze
the source of the pain is different from
most other headaches
turns out it's similar to why your feet
and hands sting when they get too cold
your body floods that area with blood to
try and return it to body temperature
and in the process your blood vessels
expand which causes that robbing pain
similarly during a brain freeze blood
vessels in your brain widen sending a
rush of blood to the roof of your mouth
and in the process causing pain now the
trigeminal nerve is a natural part of
the body so if it's the real cause of
brain freeze then that means everyone
should get it
so why do scientists estimate that only
37% of Americans actually feel it and
for that matter 41 percent of children
in Taiwan and 15% of the adults and
Denmark according to another study
researchers can only speculate
maybe the trigeminal nerve is less
sensitive in certain demographics one
thing that does seem to be clear is that
people who do experience brain freeze
may also be more susceptible to another
kind of mysterious headache migraines in
one small study 93% of migraine patients
were also prone to brain freeze which
has led researchers to suspect that the
trigeminal nerve also plays a key role
in migraines
whatever the reason just hang in there
brain freezes usually only last 20 or 30
seconds you can take those seconds to
remember not to slurp so quickly next
time what else do you want to know about
the human body let us know in the
comments and thanks for watching